Okay Michael, so, feels like we've relaxed almost
everything we could relax except for one thing. We're
now going to look at two player non zero
sum. None possibly none deterministic games of hidden information.
>> Cool.
>> And that's going to turn out to be messy, but
get us to the place where I've secretly been trying to
get us all along. So, let me describe a game
for you. Very carefully, and let's see where it leads us.
Okay, here's the game, you've got two people. These two people are criminals.
>> Oh no! Are they smooth criminals?
>> One of them is.
>> [LAUGH]
[MUSIC]
>> [LAUGH] Oh, you're terrible. Okay, so
we have two people. They're criminals. Okay,
and unfortunately they've both been captured by
the cops. I have actually no idea how
to draw that, but let's just try to draw that like this. The cops come along, and
capture them both because they are suspected in a particular robbery. Okay?
>> Hm.
>> And they take them and put them both in jail.
So those are jail bars.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay? But they don't just put them
in jails. They put them in two separate jails.
>> Oh no.
>> Okay. And one cop goes to one criminal and says
listen, here's the deal. We know you did it. Okay? We know you did.
And your friend over there, he's currently singing, singing like a bird. And he,
is going to pin it all on you. So this is your last chance to give us a little
help and admit that you two did it. Or, that the other guy did it.
You admit that the other guy does it, you say it was his fault, then we'll cut
you a deal. Now to make it worse, the
cop tells him that there's another cop over there.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Who's talking to the smooth criminal, and
is offering him the same deal.
>> Hm.
>> And whoever, goes first, whoever pins it
on the other guy first, gets to walk. Okay?
>> Hm.
>> So, if I can get the curly-head guy to defect, okay?
>> Then, I am going to let him walk and he will spend zero months in jail.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. On
the other hand, if the other guy defects, then he's going to
get to spend zero time in jail. And since we've got all
that we need. We got a confession. To get this guy to
go to jail. He's going to go to jail for nine months. Okay?
>> Negative nine months?
>> Yeah. Oh, that's a cost in months. I see. Uh-huh. [CROSSTALK]
>> Yeah that's a cost in months. Okay? So
if, curly-head guy defects before the other guy does,
then zero. He walks. He pays no cost, other than
the cost he's already paid for a life of crime.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now if he refuses to drop a dime on the other
guy, but the smooth criminal decides to defect he's going to lose nine months.
That make sense? And the other guy's going to walk. So he's
getting the same deal, they're both getting the same deal. You got it?
>> Yeah.
>> All right, now. It's a little more complicated
than that, all right? But I, I hope that you're
getting all, keeping all of this in your head. It's
a little more complicated than that. There's actually four choices
here, not just two. It's not just a case of. I
defect or the other guy defects. I defect, the other
guy doesn't. I don't defect, the other guy does. Okay? You
could both refuse to drop a dime on the other.
You could cooperate, or you could both rat out the other.
>> At the same exact moment?
>> At the same exact moment.
>> So, there's a big thick wall here. Curly guy doesn't know what
smooth guy is doing, and smooth guy doesn't know what curly guy is doing.
>> Right.
>> So the question is, if you have a choice between either defecting or.
>> Which means blaming the other guy? Which means
blaming the other guy you defecting from your friendship.
>> Oh. Or you can cooperate, that is be true to your
friendship. I can, we both people can defect, both people can cooperate,
one person can defect and the other person
cooperate, so there's actually four different options there.
>> I fee, I feel a matrix coming on.
>> Yeah, I think there's a matrix
coming on. So let's draw the matrix, because
I think that makes it easier to see. But you have the background here, right?
>> I think so, yeah.
>> The key piece here is that each person has
a choice of either defecting from their friendship or trying
to cooperate. Keeping their mouth shut, and, they don't know
what the other person is doing. So, what are all
the costs here? What are the worst case things?
Let's just draw it all out as a matrix.